[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we were
discussing about the law of kinetic
energy
and the furious inequality and we had
mentioned at the end
that we would like to arrive at some
kind of a condition which would enable
us to state
the the requirement of equilibrium
in terms of a necessary and a sufficient
condition and we had also said
that that would be the principle of
virtual work now in order to discuss
the principle of virtual work what we
need
uh is to first define
uh something called the work function so
let us discuss that first
so you consider two configurations uh
of a particular mechanical system say x
naught and
x one okay so
let's say that this is the entire
configuration space
and uh this is this point is represented
by x naught
and this point is represented by x1 and
please note
uh that as we had discussed and
emphasized in while discussing the
preliminary concepts
that these certainly do not represent
any particular material point of a
mechanical system
okay so this point although it is
represented geometrically like a point
it captures within it all the
information that is associated
with the configuration of the mechanical
system
okay so uh so this is just a
just an abstract way of representing uh
a mechanical system as it is in a
particular configuration this point
similarly
is a an abstract representation of
the same mechanical system as it is in
another configuration
all right now uh if we wish to go from x
naught
to x one there can be a number of
different possibilities in fact they can
be
uh indefinite number of possibilities so
let's say
that one such path is this
okay and we note that all the paths that
we are going to consider
will be admissible paths okay and let's
say that the
work associated with this the virtual
work associated with this
is given by w dash 1. let us consider
another admissible path like this
it will be w dash 2
let us consider another part like this
will be w dash so we can keep on
uh considering various different parts
in going from x naught to x one
now um because we are considering
different admissible parts
the values of these virtual works w dash
one w dash two w dash
three they're all going to be different
okay maybe w dash one is less than w
dash two
and maybe w dash one is greater than w
dash three
so they can they can be so many
different values associated with this
for these virtual works but
uh and suppose uh suppose you imagine
that you
that you ordered them in increasing
order
okay so suppose we have something like
this suppose
uh just for just to concretize our
example suppose
w dash three is less than w dash
one is less than w dash two and you can
keep on
doing it like this okay so
both ways if they can be other virtual
works which are less than w3
uh there can be other virtual works
which are greater than w dash
uh two and so on and so forth so
uh is there uh something unique
that can capture this values what i mean
to say is that
if see x naught and x one are two fixed
configurations
okay but we are seeing that
the various works that we are taking or
that we are
that we are taking like this they are
very much dependent
on the path that we are choosing because
as you all know
the the work done is very much a path
dependent entity
so uh would it not be good to
have something unique that is just
associated that is just dependent on
this x naught and
x one what i mean to say is that which
is path independent
and that path independent quantity as
far as
the work done is concerned is something
which is referred to
as the work fund as the work function
okay and what is that so uh if you
consider
these values to be part of a set
and that set will be the set of all the
virtual works
possible the virtual work values
possible considering different
admissible paths
in going from x naught to x one then
uh there will be a least upper bound
to this set okay so
if we consider this thing okay so if we
considered
these values to be
part of a set and when i said i really
do mean
a set in the mathematical sense as we
studied in our high school
maths okay so if you consider these
values to be part of a set
and we
we considered mechanical systems
which
do not possess infinite energy okay so
this is just a careful way of setting up
the statement
which do not possess
infinite energy okay which is basically
to say
most mechanical systems of interest
especially of engineering interest okay
so if you consider mechanical systems
which do not possess infinite energy
uh so as long as we don't do that in
fact i mean it's just a pedantic way of
saying this but
i mean most engineering system like most
absolutely most engineering systems you
can say will not poses infinite energy
so we are mostly safe
here if we consider these values to be
part of a set
then the then
this set
will have a least upper bound
will have something called a least upper
bound
what is this least upper bound entity
so we'll have a least upper bound let's
call this w so this w
is such that no matter
no matter which w dash
we choose
this will be no matter which
w dash we choose
that w dash is guaranteed to be less
than
this w so it is in that sense that this
w
is referred to as the least upper bound
okay so this is just a
set theoretic way of looking at it but
you understand what is going on okay in
a physical sense
so uh if we if we arrange all these
virtual work
done possible in increasing order
ultimately
there will be a an upper limit to it
okay in a very uh a very lay man
kind of language if we say like that uh
probably it'll make sense to you
okay so of all the w dashes uh if you
considered
there will it is guaranteed to be less
than a certain value
and that value okay of course you can
have higher values
than this you can consider something
like twice w you can consider like
thrice w or maybe w plus delta w
something like that
but all of those will be higher than w
so among all those things
there will be a list value so which is
why we call this as the least upper
bound
which is guaranteed to be such that all
the virtual works that we are
considering like this
will be less than this okay
so it may seem like an unnecessarily
complicated way of looking at it
but there is a very nice utility
associated with this w which is that w
is path independent the moment you think
about it
path independent okay all these w dashes
okay these w dash are
part dependent this is very important to
[Music]
note
okay all these w dashes they are path
dependent
whereas this w is path independent
okay which means that w is
purely a function of the two
configurations that we are interested in
w is just a function of x naught
and x one it does not matter what
admissible parts you are you may be
considering
okay the associated with
a pair of configurations there is a
unique
uh w work function
which is such that no matter what
admissible paths you may consider
in between them the work the virtual
work associated with each of those
admissible parts is current to be
less than this w so these are very
useful quantity
okay and in terms of this useful
quantity we can actually restate
our fouriers inequality which we are
discussing earlier
so fouriers in inequality if we say
that in
rewrite that
fourier's inequality can be written in
terms of
this w so if we say that this w
is less than equal to zero then it is
automatically guaranteed
that no matter which admissible paths
you may be thinking
the virtual work associated with all of
them is also less than equal to zero
okay because all of them are less than w
so it's very neat okay
so all these w dashes you may be
considering
they are guaranteed to be less than w
and because w is itself less than equal
to zero
so you can understand this this w dash
will be less than zero
all right so in that and that way the
fourier's inequality
can be stated in a path independent
fashion
now all this is fine okay what about the
principle of virtual work
so what we'll do is we'll state the
principle of virtual work
right away in terms of this work
function
so there can be certain certain and
quite a lot of subtleties associated
with the principle of virtual work
but at this point for you know in a very
uh
again speaking in a very utility and
fashion we don't have to go into all
those subtleties
it is enough for us to cons to to state
that
uh for the principle of virtual work we
first consider the work function
associated with two configurations and
this w it can be
data expanded and written
in this fashion as we have seen so many
times a couple of times earlier
delta w plus half delta squared w so
this is the first variation of w
this is the second variation of w and we
can have higher order terms
now it may seem like a little bit of a
jump to
suddenly arrive at this but please note
that since we are talking about
w associated with with different
configurations
it is very much in sync with whatever we
had discussed earlier
for example um first of all uh
in terms of the calculus of variations
what we have discussed or the or the
integration i
as well as later on in terms of the
virtual displacements when we
when we uh arrived at a statement like
this in our earlier lecture
in one of our earlier lectures so uh
so written like this this is certainly
not the principle of virtual work this
is just the tailored
expansion of the work function what the
principle of virtual work states
is that the
necessary and sufficient condition for
a mechanical system to be in equilibrium
is that
delta w must be equal to zero the the
first variation
of the work function must be equal to
zero
okay so or equilibrium
okay
now uh remember what we were discussing
in terms of the fourier's inequality
being violated up for that little
example
of a of a marble sitting on top of a
doom
uh there if you if you find out the
work done by the force of gravity or a
little virtual displacement of that
marble
away from that equilibrium position it
will give you a
positive value but what we said was that
because the fourier's inequality is only
a sufficient condition
and not a necessary condition so even if
the force of gravity
does a positive work we cannot conclude
that the
the marble or the little ball is uh
not in equilibrium okay and actually it
is in equilibrium it's just in
just an unstable equilibrium so
uh like if we if we really go into the
deep details of the calculation
we'll find out that uh even for such an
example
it is the first variation which
definitely is equal to zero
uh for that for that example but uh it's
the second variation which is not
zero and uh that can have some
interesting discussions but we since we
are not talking about
stability right away let's not get into
our unnecessary detail about that
okay so what is important is that for
equilibrium delta w
is greater than zero and this is the
principle of virtual work
so
of course i have made it rather
simplistic if i'm stating
it like this so
there are certain subtleties associated
with this also for example the forces
should not change
discontinuously and
we have to be careful about certain
considerations but the good thing is
that for the kind of systems that we'll
be interested in
in our course of advanced mechanics of
solids this is this is
uh going to be good enough for us now in
terms of the actual operations
associated with this principle of
virtual
work uh what we'll do often is that we
will decompose this
delta w and mind you that this delta w
is a work function
associated with both the internal and
external forces so what we'll say is
that uh
we'll decompose this from uh as
as a as contributions from the internal
forces and the external forces
separately
okay so what we'll say is that this
delta w
uh is equal to zero but this delta w
itself
is contributed uh from the forces
due to the inter from the from the
internal forces as well as
those due to the external forces so
overall
what we have is the first variation of
delta of w internal is equal to the
negative
of the first variation of
the work done external okay now i think
in certain books or in certain
resources if you look at in the internet
also uh
sometimes the principle of virtual work
is stated that
the work done by the internal forces is
equal to the work done by the external
forces
but uh stated in this careful fashion i
mean if you
if you really take care of the signs it
is like the negative of it okay but
magnitude wise it is the same
okay now this particular form
of the principle of virtual work this is
something which will be using
time and again all throughout our
course of advanced mechanics of solids
in fact this is something which we are
going to use
directly in our next topic of discussion
which is
the uh the work done associated with a
deformable body
and that will set us up uh set us out on
on a rather intense discussion
of all the energy methods associated
uh some of the important energy methods
associated
with deformable bodies please note that
till now whatever we have been
discussing
that has been associated with generic
mechanical systems whether they were
deformable or rigid it did not matter
but from now on we will be specializing
our discussion
uh based on this principle of virtual
work
but applied to uh deformable
bodies all right thank you very much
we'll
continue we'll start our discussion of
the bodies from the next
video